foreign
San Diego California what's up Mike how
we doing
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it man what's up
so
um I'm at a point in my life where I
just I don't know what to do anymore and
I'm just really stressed out and
depressed and
I'm just I don't see the light at the
end of the tunnel anymore
um tell me about it man so how about I
have a construction business and it does
okay I mean I it does enough to pay the
bills
um
but I'm just I'm I don't even feel
motivated to grow it
um and
I'm just lost at what I want to do
where does the loss come from man
what you're describing is describing
work you're describing you know this you
got you got a wife you got kids
uh I have a girlfriend
um and we have one kid together okay I
just I went through a divorce of three
years ago okay and that was it that
messed me up mentally and financially
yeah
um was that where it started this idea
that
no matter what you do this is just gonna
kind of be the way this is
um
did you pick that up when you were a kid
where'd that come from man somebody gave
you that story that crappy things happen
this is the way this is and maybe you
can go to a couple of ball games and a
couple of concerts and your kid will be
a good soccer star in elementary school
and that's kind of the kind of the joy
you get who told you that man
yeah I'm not sure I'm just
I don't know
I just I'm really lost that's why I'm
trying to find
what my purpose is basically
so so what do you want to do man
like if you can snap your fingers right
now what would you want to do
well I mean I love what I do in
business-wise like work I love the
construction business
um what do you love about them what I
love about it
I love building creating
um just everything about it do you like
working with customers do you like
planning and sitting with Architects or
do you like getting a crew of guys
together and going to solve a problem
and or do you like picking up the shovel
and just getting after yourself what do
you like about it
uh more like the managing side of
getting things together and
um
just
so uh labor side I mean I'm doing all
the labor right now but I feel I'm more
good at
putting everything together and getting
everything going okay what about your
what about your kids tell me about your
kid
yeah he's uh two years old yeah um
what's his name
is
he fun is he a mess he's all over the
place
oh yeah he's he's really active
active is what exhausted fathers say so
they can remind themselves I still love
you I still love you I still love you
he's very active well done man so Mike
outside of your career and obviously
you've got you know your personal life
at home if you could snap your fingers a
year from now what do you think would
transform your life to where you wake up
and you're excited now what's keeping
you up at night right now that we can
help with
oh
is it money or do you have money
problems
are you not happy with your relationship
well that's another I think that's my
biggest stress right now is the money's
bad because I meant that with friends
and Families
um close to twenty thousand twenty
thousand and that's credit card debt and
personal loans
no no credit card or personal mostly to
friends and family why are you borrowing
money from friends and family dude
all right that
well my business slowed down for a while
and I was just trying to make things and
just trying to make anything what's your
income
um I'm a big month and like
5 000. okay and is your girlfriend
working are you guys splitting bills how
is this working
no my girlfriend she's a stay-at-home
mom at this moment okay so you're the
Sole Provider right now
yeah you got a mortgage
no no mortgage I'm renting how much is
your rent
1800.
that's a lot of rent for your income
yeah
yeah could you guys uh downsize could
you move I don't know in San Diego huh
yeah well I I've tried looking at
something cheaper but everything is just
it's all right the other option is we
got to get this income up if we're gonna
choose to live in San Diego
and so that becomes you're the next
piece of the puzzle you are you're
running this business
yeah yeah but you're also are you the
sole employee or do you have people
working for you
no I'm just a sole employee okay
so to scale how do we get this thing to
where you're making a hundred grand
well I I've been applying
um with construction companies as
project manager just
um and
I get emails saying that my application
and resumes getting a lot of attention
but I have not got one interview and I
I've applied to over 30 places I think
yeah so dude let that tell you a story
that you want to be a project manager at
a construction company you know how to
do that and 30 different companies have
said
we don't think you're quite there yet
awesome
go to the next rung right below that and
go in there
as a head of projects or ahead of
something or ahead of the construction
whatever whatever part of construction
you're really good at pouring concrete
doing landscape whatever you're good at
and get your foot in the door
you're you're absorbing every rejection
as
a statement about Mike's worth
not just somebody saying no I don't
think that's the right job for you or I
got somebody else in line for this or
everybody in California is trying to
find work and so we've got you like
at some point it because like you've got
some skills I'm thinking of you right
now me and George can't do what you do
like if we can't just run our mouths on
the radio I don't like we're in a mess
you can build a thing you can fix a
thing
does that make sense
yeah I I want to see a couple of things
I want you to call betterhelp.com today
and betterhelp.com deloney and it's
going to give you a discount I want you
to go talk to a counselor okay I think
you're struggling with depression
thinking to call somebody the second
thing is we're gonna send you Ken
Coleman's get clear assessment and
proximity principle teach you to get
close to some of these guys and I want
you to read it and I'm gonna send you
fbu Financial Peace University but you
and your girlfriend have to go through
these classes stop playing house get
married start settling into this thing
and dude the light will come on if you
will look for it my brother we got you